hey James wasn't it kind of annoying
that you had to type out the same
statement twice yeah I think I broke one
of the cardinal rules of programming
don't repeat yourself yeah
and with that in mind I think it's
probably time that we should talk about
loops so is that why we're looking at an
animated gif okay that's one reason the
second is because that is an awesome
gift but really I think the important
part here is that a gift repeats itself
automatically we don't have to tell the
gift to play itself again it just does
it and in fact JavaScript gives us a few
tools to do this as well and we're gonna
go ahead and start with a while loop a
while loop lets us repeat a piece of
code so long as some condition evaluates
to true once it doesn't evaluate to true
we exit the while loop the syntax is
while condition and then in curly braces
some sort of code here so for this one
we have do something hey let's let's
show an example okay while Cameron that
job is equal to course developer he
should make courses I like that example
notice how this is similar to Python but
includes conditions in parentheses and
actions and curly braces just like with
if statements remember if the condition
evaluates to true we'll do the action
and then ask ourselves again is a
condition true we'll continue following
this loop until the condition is no
longer true
at which point we'll exit the loop over
here so long as my job is course
developer I'll keep making courses the
while loop will ask itself again is
Cameron still a course developer if so
make courses until at some point when my
job is no longer course developer at
which point we'll exit the loop how
might that happen mmm perhaps there's a
limit on how many courses I can make ten
courses maximum you know what let's see
what this looks like in code outside of
the loop I'll create an iterator called
courses which is going to start at zero
this is going to keep track of how many
courses I've made after making a course
I'm going to add one to the number of
courses that I've made let's add an if
statement to our loop that checks if the
number of courses I've made is ten and
if so changes
my job to learning specialist afterwards
the loop exits interesting let's check
to see if that works here's the make
course function that console logs made a
course every time it's run and lets
console that log
Cameron's job when were finish running
the loop so when we run it we can see
that it's printed made a course to the
console log ten times and then when it
finished it printed out learning
specialists Cameron's new job